SCP-173 also known as the sculpture is a
euclid-class humanoid entity contained
by the SCP Foundation it appears to be a
statue made of concrete and rebar with
inanimate and aggressive nature SCP-173
is extremely fast and can move only when
it is not being observed by any living
creature when SCP-173 is observed even
momentarily it freezes in place however
it will quickly attack any living
creature within its line of sight when
it's not being observed usually by
snapping its victim's neck SCP-173 also
has the ability to regenerate from
damage making it extremely difficult to
contain SCP-173 was discovered in an
abandoned building and is believed to
have been created by an unknown artist
due to its violent and unpredictable
nature
scp-173s to be contained in a sealed
chamber at all times and is to be
monitored constantly by at least two
Personnel any breach of containment is
to be dealt with immediately and with
extreme force